martin biron al tirage ottawa à
christian dufour bonsoir là je dois
faire mon mea culpa non pas à vous
mouiller au téléspectateur gmi lebel sur
quevillon sur quévillon en abitibi tout
à l'heure je suis allé trouver parce
qu'on allait rejoindre notre journaliste
qui est à val d'or en abitibi
évidemment lebel sur quévillon ce à deux
heures au nord
c'est dans la région administrative nord
du québec
toutes mes excuses j'ai reçu quelques
lettres gentil et d'autres moins gentil
alors voilà c'est rectifier et on les
saluer parce qu'ils pourront ils ont eu
le vaccin toute la population au nord du
québec
on revient à ce qui sera peut-être
annoncé cette semaine on a parle depuis
quoi deux trois semaines des mesures
plus restrictives pour les voyageurs je
vous fais en tarder
non je serai pas en tant que personne je
veux faire un tour de table martin
d'abord dont le québec et d'autres
provinces mettre beaucoup de pression
est-ce que d'après vous c'est inévitable
ça s'en vient pour savoir rassurer ou
pas monsieur legault mais monsieur
legault veut des mesures concrètes et
street mais il n'y a aucune
communication réelle entre le cabinet de
monsieur legault et cabinet de monsieur
trudeau c'est à dire que à québec on n'a
aucune idée de ce qui est
dans le collimateur on ne sait pas ce
que monsieur trudeau va faire et ça ça
les vins common passablement à québec
bon altia comment vous voyez le bras de
fer actuel en d'abord entre les
provinces certaines provinces et ottawa
et au sein du cabinet on ne s'entend pas
nécessairement sur la meilleure marche à
suivre donc
même audrey qui sont encore prêts à
dévoiler quoi que ce soit on dirait
qu'ils ont passé beaucoup de temps à se
dire qu'ils avaient fait vous allez déjà
pris de fortes mesures que l'effet des
mesures que la ford et au pays avait pas
de prix alors qu'ils savaient pas besoin
de faire quoi que ce soit mais à cause
en partie je pense à nouvelle variante
celles qui proviennent d'angleterre 1
puis le fait que le 1er mai ce logo le
premier ministre oui en partie parce que
c'était une stratégie de communication
un détournement les choses ont pas
nécessairement superbe province une
stratégie bien connue au créateur mais
maintenant ils regardent soit par les
tests rapides
alejo par une suggestion ils ont aussi
étudié mais quarantaine dans les hôtels
forcé comme en nouvelle zélande comme en
australie
il sent pas pouvoir changer la directive
qui vivent de ne pas voyager pour de ne
pas prendre des voyages non essentiels à
l'étranger sont juste pour dire ne
voyageait pas moins à la nuit peut-être
que ça va venir
1 800 penser que le premier disque sort
presque tous les jours pour jours au
canada ne pas vous christian dufour on
parlait un représentant d'air transat
qui nous disait en fait je lui ai
suggéré l'image me disait en effet c'est
le supplice de la goutte est déjà nous
on a à peu près plus d'avions et là on
aurait peut-être savoir s'ils veulent
être plus sévère qu'ils ne soient tout
de suite là parce qu'on ne peut plus
nous oui mais on peut dire que les
admonestations pire augmentation et
divertissements de monsieur trudeau on
sort sur un effet parce qu'il semble
plus avoir beaucoup de gens qui veulent
voyager au canada les gens qu'on gaz de
schiste un voyage aujourd'hui c'est
risquer d'être parieurs c'est risqué de
de souffrir donc je sais que deux points
du québécois parce que vraiment eu
d'affrontement legault trudeau dans plus
qu'avec les autres promesses
au québec c'est presque unanime des
mauges partage pomme de plus seul mais
les gens voudraient qu'on confirme les
français qu'on empêche les québécois et
des canadiens de voyager moi je pense
d'un secret des yeux mais on sent qu'à
ottawa un énorme sens à ottawa on fait
plus la différence qu'on fait + 10 au
québec entre les québécois et les
canadiens qui sort du pays ce qui va
leur revenir
agir sur ce qui va le revenu c'est
beaucoup plus facile est acceptable
on peut aller très loin moi je trouve
qu'on peut être dans l'hystérie le
délire mais parce que ça c'est comme ça
s'accepte plus je pense qu'avant je
crois pas du tout à l'autre bout
j'espère poche doit tirer je ne crois
pas qu'ils vont empêcher les canadiens
et les québécois de partir et moi ça me
confiait du compte je me sens prêt de
l'appel comme québécois ne voir qu'un
consensus unanime au québec où on veut
empêcher les québécois de partir pour
rien c'est un droit conventionnel mais
là est ce qu'ils vont être capables
d'agir
jusqu'où ils vont agir pour le retour
pour pour encadrer les calaisiens qui
sont partis
rappelons qu'à l'échelle de 10 à l'autre
on trouve que le système canadien est
déjà plus très que dans la part des
autres pays et les autres canaliser des
autres les étrangers ne peuvent pas
venir au canada on impose une
quarantaine de 14 jours dont on peut
discuter de sérieux en ne mâchant pas
quant à bombay à les conseils des
nombres et de 100 de la chaîne dénonce
alain pignon l'emblème mariale et varia
les variables angoisse deux mois début
de panique mois et des variants qui sont
dans le coup les vaccins en fait qu'on
semble avoir moins qu'ailleurs
donc tous ces facteurs le rejouer une
opinion publique extrêmement clairs en
particulier au québec et à ottawa
moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils veulent pas
aller trop martin d'après vous est-ce
qu'on armait un peu aussi fort à québec
elle tient dix l as un vieux truc du
livre lapointe médecine détourne la
pression sur l'autre gouvernement
l'autre panier ou six indiens y pas leur
affaire nous on est aux prises avec sens
oui il ya une inquiétude réelle tout le
monde s'entend sur le var yahoo
bien sûr mais l'insistance avec laquelle
monsieur legault parle de ça qu'est ce
que ça vous dit il ya deux choses à dire
là dessus c'est vrai que monsieur
legault ne déteste pas donné un coup de
griffe monsieur trudeau il le fait
depuis la dernière campagne électorale
et il le fait il leur fait régulièrement
je parle avec un élu qui disait mon bon
vieux sont souverainistes est toujours
un peu rassuré quand monsieur legault
fait ça alors il parle un peu à sa bosse
quand il le fait la deuxième chose
puisqu'il faut remonter un petit peu
dans le temps l'engouement en fait pour
lui le désir de partir des citoyens au
québec est venue quand monsieur legault
en novembre dernier annuler les fêtes de
noël et quatre jours de rassemblements
et sans le gouvernement ne l'avait pas
vu venir il n'y a pas envoyé un message
clair qu'ils ne voulaient pas qu'il
voyage on a allumé au québec que les
gens étaient pour voyager à quelques
jours de noël tandis que pour la relâche
scolaire
les messages sont clairs le gouvernement
le premier ministre à québec disent
régulièrement aux gens de ne pas voyager
et effectivement ça semble fonctionner
parce que si air transat annule ses vols
c'est que les gens annulent leurs
voyages
oui elle tient joutes politiques
en même temps crainte réelle m doyen qui
disait parce que il souligne à chaque
fois mais c'est évident il n'y a que
deux pour ça des cas qu'on a pu recenser
qui sont son qui proviennent de gens qui
ont voyagé qui revient de l'étranger ben
quoi qu'on pense
on n'a pas toutes les données de tous
mais on sent qu'il est vraiment pris
entre deux feux ou investie bret qui
veulent pas vraiment prendre des mesures
plus strictes qu'ils ont déjà pris ils
savent pas exactement quoi faire
il fait même si on dit aux gens qui
reviennent au canada disons qu'ils
doivent payer une amende on met là est
ce que on punit les gens qui reviennent
au pays qu'ils étaient à
conduit pendant des années est-ce que
comment est ce qu'on peut détailler les
gens qui sont partis pour peut-être des
funérailles puis des gens qui sont
partis parce qu'ils veulent aller à
cancun alors il ya plein qu'elles sont
là dedans c'est certain qu'ils veulent
pas dire aux gens ils veulent pas
prévenir les gens d'affaires je ne veux
pas forcer de vie reste au canada mais
c'est certain qu'il va avoir une
pression on l'a déjà dit le matin pile
elle me dit le premier ministre l'a dit
la semaine dernière
ils vont sortir avec des nouvelles
mesures parce que deux pour ça je crois
qu'en fait c'est un peu moins de 2% mais
c'est quand même deux courses de trot
puis mais eux ils sont en train de
tourner ça pour ça on sait qu'il ya
plusieurs cas dans les écoles pourquoi
vous avez dit voyez les tests rapides
dans les écoles on sait que beaucoup de
cas comme en alberta dans les centres
alimentaire où on traitait du boeuf à
exemple quoi il y avait pas de tests
rapides dans ces endroits là c'est pas
entre selon moi j'ai lu pas s'en sortir
oui christian en conclusion les revenir
en fait sur les attaques de monsieur
legault contre monsieur trudeau c'est
clair que le parti manoeuvre de
diversion sur les finales parce que
c'est tellement et ans la façon dont
monsieur legault harcèle que demain
monsieur trudeau là dessus et moi j'ai
l'impression répertorier tous là à 10
ans il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
acheté cette ligne là partout dans les
médias ne trouve l'animisme logique ça
votre égérie la même chose mais vous
avez raison attire le souhait mais moi
j'ai l'impression que monsieur trudeau
gagnent du temps etc jusqu'à un certain
point rentable parce qu'aujourd'hui je
pense pas que beaucoup de gens qui
partent encore dans le et vous savez il
ya quelques mois tout le monde parlait
de l'application là pour retracer la
copie
suivi de sa patrie ce bon monsieur le
voit en parler en parler moi je me
demande si dans quelques semaines
cette focalisation sur les voyages à
l'étranger ça sera pas un souvenir
ok vaccin vaccin on écoute monsieur
autour qui pose une question monsieur
trudeau aujourd'hui après des questions
et une partie de la réponse de monsieur
trudeau l'union européenne va contrôler
et l'exportation des vaccins c'est une
protectionnisme vaccinale il y à un
risque de surenchère des vaccins
monsieur le président c'est une
compétition phare hausse à l'échelle
mondiale est ce que le premier ministre
a appelé les dirigeants européens pour
assurer
no comment
j'ai parlé à forcer la vente d'art line
la président de la commission européenne
justement pour souligner nos
préoccupations à à ce niveau là on est
tous inquiets de pouvoir recevoir les
doses de vaccins qu'on a qu'on a acheté
pas qu'on a ce contrat et j'ai été
rassuré que la les mesures de
transparence que vont être prises par
l'europe ne vont pas affecter les
livraisons de file de moderna au canada
bon pour assurer le tour de ta vraie
paix de là dessus martin bahia encore là
monsieur leubou a donné un petit coup de
griffe cette semaine à monsieur trudeau
à xambes et nous on est on est prêt
anele les doses on est deux semaines en
avance et on veut aller plus vite
alors il met beaucoup de pression pour
qu'ils aient cessées dose et mahé petit
je pense que à peu près tout le monde
s'attendait à ce que l'opération de
vaccination ne soit pas nécessairement
un long fleuve tranquille
alors qu'il ya quand même une
compétition dans le monde entier pour
obtenir des doses et on voit bien que ça
ses salaires bon elle tient je pense
c'est malheureusement une dans les
premiers mois on a moins de tous ce
qu'on s'attendait mais je pense que si
la vaccination se déroule comme la
fédérale le deal entre moquant d'elle et
kraft millions minimum de dos de gens
vaccinés level d'ici la fin du mois de
septembre
mais je pense que personne n'ose
vraiment chanceux christian ouais je
pense que le dossier va classer le
dossier de loin le plus importantes pour
les canadiens et pour le gouvernement
et si on voit c'est une grande fragilité
quand même de la position canadienne
dans le dossier des vaccins j'espère que
ça va
et si on ajoute et varius les barrios
des variantes du virus au groupe des
variances des variantes du virus qui
inquiète tout le monde sur lequel on ne
sait pas beaucoup de choses puis si on
ajoute les vaccins ça explique entre
autres espèces par moments que je me
dise terrer dans le dossier des voyages
à l'étranger c'est qu'on n'est pas juste
dans le rationnel
objectivement on est tous un peu inquiet
on est dans la peur mais bien celui là
par créer des réactions irrationnelles
jeu
montrez une publicité du blog facebook
ce matin qui a été retirée rapidement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
le premier ministre on pouvait lire ne
t'a pas au lieu d'interdire les vols non
essentiels c'est agir en agents de bord
plutôt qu'en pilotes et leurs le tweet
du bloc qui est arrivée après que tous
les agents de bord du pays ont appelé à
peu près tous les journalistes du pays
alors on peut lire dans le tweet du bloc
le bloc québécois présente ses excuses à
tout ceux et celles qui ont été blessées
en particulier à chambord par un carré
web publiée hier c'était une erreur nous
l'avons retirée rapidement
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire et tour de
table le retiennent en politique
colorer son message faire passer son
message seuil est trouvée métaphore
c'est une obsession mais des fois c'est
un couteau à deux tranchants et pour
ceux qui connaissent ils françois
blanchette savent qu'il peut colorer
très
ce de façon soutenue ces propos alors il
ya eu l'aide de peinture c'est
malheureux mais une chance que se sont
excusés qui si seulement monsieur
blanchet s'est excusé pour les propos
qu'elle vit aussi de monsieur omar al
khadra je pense que ça a été encore on
va reparler de ça parce que il ya loin
des excuses le bloc aussi lundi annoncer
des questions légitimes sur ce mini des
transports merci beaucoup à vous trois
c'est tout le temps qu'on a merci à très
bientôt
merci
[Musique]
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit